what is something that you regret
there's a guy I kind of wish I hadn't
let go of that's a bit of a regret um he
wanted to settle down and I didn't I
wasn't ready to um we were still quite
young and he did settle down and he did
have a family and I'm super happy for
him because I think he found the right
woman and he and he's living his best
life but I really like this guy and I
still kind of like this guy I do see him
on Facebook and I I wish him well but
there's just a tiny part of me that
thinks
huh how would that have worked out it's
interesting when you start interviewing
people because you start to see like the
same characters at different stages of
their lives and you can typically
predict how their lives work out